hansel and gretel witch hunters is so
much fun it is just one big entertaining
cheeseball fest everything about it is
cheesy the action is cheesy the visual
effects all the gore there's a lot of
gore the film has kickass toys and the
acting is also cheesy although at times
it did seem like Hansel and Gretel
wanted to [ __ ] at first the comedy
doesn't quite work but once the movie
finds its groove everything becomes
solidly bad it's sort of like a
throwback to like 90s action movies with
a hint of sam reny in there it's just so
much fun I don't know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with everyone else I mean for
crying out loud it's produced by Will
Ferrell did you really expect movie with
a lot of substance the most
uninteresting parts of this movie part
of course the scenes with drama and
dialogue but those scenes don't really
last long it's mainly just there for
exposition and information to get back
to pretty much non-stop action all in
all I got to say Hansel and Gretel witch
hunters got it right
you